went into barcelona got rid of the big
names the ones that they said the
company ronaldinho ibrahimovic and all
that flipped football on it must have
been an absolute nightmare that i'm just
gonna decide to get rid of ronaldinho
he's not quite fitting what i want to do
as a manager
in the top division of football but i
ain't going to say joel royale's better
than jurgen klopp it wasn't the question
[Music]
hello mate how are you mate
good
spot
i feel like this is probably about as
close you've been to city all season
well there's a bit of a gap
emerging at the minute
jurgen klopp is a better manager than
pet guardiola pound for pound
three
two
one
ow
how could he possibly powerful pounds
pound for pound yeah what's well you're
not old i'm athletic okay you're not
working on a like a 200 gram budget are
you yeah yeah but you know but jagan
klopp has
been that he has literally been not in
his progression as a manager no you
can't compare him it's just you've won
one title in 30 years yeah and the
european cup so he's won two trophies
i'm not counting on mickey mouse things
that you go abroad for and all that
forget them so premier league
the premier league and then european cup
yeah yeah
pep guardiola just ripped up english
football yeah absolutely destroyed oh
and jay and james football and spanish
football before then but what clubs did
he do it with yeah because it's like you
being a manager or or a top brass in a
massive company and then a small company
and then somebody offering you a job at
a little tiny company you ain't taking
it are you because you're going to think
why should i go work for them when i'm
working way up here yeah yeah but if
someone also work their way into the
level having come through every single
stage along the way together
i would understand that they're better
at what i do than i am barcelona b went
into barcelona got rid of the big names
the ones that they said the company
ronaldinho ibrahimovic and all that
flipped football on it must have been an
absolute nightmare that i'm just gonna
decide to get rid of ronaldinho he's not
quite fitting what i want to do as a
manager oh my god what an absolutely
taking club marriage mates
into the top division of german football
right so who's going to sit there at the
end of the career if big dave down the
road tells you that klopp's better than
pep it doesn't mean he is big things
down the road could do big day down the
road silverware
barcelona with bayern munich
well come on you you know you're not a
kid in it you know that you've got to
coach them teams and with them teams to
become special hey listen you will not
get an argument from me
this is not a do you think pep guardiola
is a good manager agree or strongly
disagree we're talking about path for
pounds and pedigree pep guardiola and
jacob are the two best managers in world
football but even pep guardiola himself
has admitted he could not have done the
job that jagan klopp has done with the
class that he's had i need to see where
he's admitted that because
he's a lovely fellow pep he's a very
horrible
he knows that he's he's had
a depth of quality and resources at the
football clubs that he's
had the european company
you spent more money than anyone's ever
spent in one window wow there you go so
you wonder so you can call us for buying
the league but you did it i didn't call
you for buying them no but liverpool
fans do you can only do where money pet
can only do with money but clock can
only do it with money because you've
done it yeah every time he hasn't spent
that money you aren't one nope look at
this [ __ ] i'm not talking about ireland
i'm not talking about man city and
liverpool we're talking about powerful
pounds
this year no striker you know what i
mean just just gone and said right we're
sticking with all striker we're 13
points ahead right so he's making a
mickey mouse of it yeah at the minute so
that'll be what four premier leagues in
five it's easy with money but when he
when he when he had probably been left
back easy air with money not because you
do you'll disagree yeah of course of
course it is because
it's harder with less money right here's
one for you then you've still got to
coach that team to a level to which is
an absolute elite level and without pep
guardiola have you ever seen rocky iv of
course yeah
you and pep guardiola's teams are ivan
drago and
you're talking about the underdog story
the guy who's gone it's against the game
they've got a cool small team against a
bit you know are you trying to say that
like we're drago when you're and it
should be your way around we're rocking
and you're dragging because you've got
all the history
and all that no pep guardiola's dragon
because he's got all the scientists got
all the money he's getting all this
stuff that's going on gold support and
jagan club has come up from the black
forest drag teams out of nowhere
see that there that's the smallest
violin in the world playing for you i'll
tell you what come on man but powerful
pound you know you're talking about
someone who comes up from who is
self-made who drags things up himself
without resources around him is there
not a greater
quality and skill involved in achieving
not at that level i could say the other
way i could say pep guardiol sorry
jurgen klopp gets a job at man city gets
a massive bank balance yeah splurges it
all on absolute garbage and don't win
nothing because he's never had the money
because that's happened before okay
managers have come in spent a load of
money and it's not worked so you can you
there's two sides of the coin i think
it's more likely the club could have
achieved similar to what guardiola did
at city and i think it's it's slightly
less likely that guardiola could have
done it and that's only because we've
never seen guardiola take a club that
was nowhere and make them into something
he's only ever been at super clubs when
you have to compare and it's annoying to
have to compare to either two because we
should be able to put them both up right
on top of the pedestal next to one
another but in terms of how they've made
that climb to the top pep guardiola and
jagan klopp ident klopp's done it in a
far more
he's come up the hard way compared to
pep which makes him pound for pound
better lately vincent company was a
better defender than virgil van dijk is
now
three
two
one
our companies was amazing really really
good
but
there's no bus boards it's good virgil
van dyke no chance no one ever
called vincent company the best center
half on the planet and that's what
virgil van dijk is
nah i'm not having it well obviously
but why
i'm not having it because it's the i'm
sure you'd like just make up quote who
called him the best center out on the
planet club
a genuinely acceptable it's not in
liverpool maybe who's the better
centered off are you going to say diaz
you're going to say yes he's up there
but he's not bad but when he comes to
vincent vincent had the whole mentality
issue he dragged a club that was didn't
have that winning mentality we never had
it we was getting to games and bottling
it but he was just like you know what
i'm a leader the derby game when we were
chasing united down and we and and you
just see the focus in the tunnel we
needed to win if we lose it's over and
he gets the goal
the run against you where we have to win
them games
40-yard screamer from the center half
top corner yeah takes us to the title
that unbelievable yeah and virgil van
dyke is a fantastic player and when we
were linked with him i was thinking get
him it's game over and virgil at the
minute currently playing
he he probably is up there with the best
but he nearly said the best no i just i
did just something else
a bit about him i just don't think he's
quite there yet you mean given that he's
been out with a cruciate he's been out
with it with the knee injury he was good
for liverpool in that season you won the
league but there's been a few times
where he's not been that commanding
that's not true no he's not though this
season this season has not been the same
again when he's on the way back from i
know but come on is it excuse fc again
we can all throw excuses how many
interesting how many injuries did
vincent company have oh yeah yeah you
know i mean vincent company was barely
playing games we were wrapping him in
cotton wool but again we're talking
about van dyke who was in the running
for the ballon d'or you know what bins
and companies never been close ballon
d'or things yeah because you won the
european cup in it but we didn't if we
don't won the european cup diaz got to
the final last year he was in running
for ballon d'or come about 40 50. don't
mean now does it yeah but virgil van
dyke didn't come forward
i'm judging on vincent company dragging
man city to trophies i'm drinking i'm
judging on virgil van dyke dragging you
to one league title
and the champions league
yeah so two champions league final no
the finals don't count right but the ass
you just mentioned the us getting into
the final yeah for the ballon d'or point
but i'm not counting that as a as a
trophy like you oh no no who's currently
you just said you just said it's your
final you're bringing up like getting to
finals dragon football clubs or no
ballon d'ors and all that to me i'm
talking about vincent company and
trophies my point on virgo van dijk is
that because we put so much emphasis on
attacking players i genuinely in tears
of him as a footballer
there's a there's a case the vegematic
in the last three seasons injury
notwithstanding is in the clutch of the
actual best footballers in the game not
just but we don't talk about defenders
being the best footballers in the game
because everyone focuses on the lads who
score the lads who make things he's a
leader he's incredibly composing the
ball he redefined there's a new stat in
in the game and it's
managed to get past virgil van dyke
people put clips out on twitter
oh look you got past fantasy
generally but but that's how significant
verge of hyundai is the people see it as
a badge of honor nobody ever talked
about man city being a good defensive
team nobody ever talked about them being
water tight people used to talk about
the great football the attack on
football and the goals they scored but
no one went man city you cannot get past
them because this guy and this defender
and that's what virgil van dijk brought
to liverpool liverpool won the title on
you just couldn't score pastors he made
us into a rock-solid unit and also he's
absolutely beautiful as well and he's
all over the place he's an icon and
vincent company has just
worried about him well class yeah as
long as they're not around to be fine
virgil van dijk is
i think the the peak the creme de la
creme up there in that thinnest of thin
slices of the greatest center halves of
all time i don't think companies far
behind that but i don't think he had a
transformative effect and went from city
being like
super conceding goals week in week out
and he didn't solve that problem he just
went to winning he just dragged us the
trophy isn't it but not but he wasn't he
wasn't as pivotal in the way that the
way the city constructed their titles as
aguero's goals were or silva's assist
where etc i just named you two moments
that vincent company in two title runs
that one is it yeah that header against
united without that we don't win the
league and then we're chasing you down
you're on a mad run and we left off
frustrated to death you sent her off
it's a 40-yard world you're right in the
top corner yeah i think you need to take
the liverpool glasses off and just
realize that vincent company is quality
i never said he wasn't it's just not as
good as virgil vancouver we'll see
pep's best man city side
was better than klopp's best liverpool
side
three
two
one
what what's his best what was his best
city i probably i'd probably go
centurion team
that's definitely the only one that got
more points than or or you can go to
season you can go to season after the
one that won every trophy so but i'd go
centurion because
i just think the levels were that high
and especially when you've got a
liverpool team breathing down your neck
i think it just
it just
unbelievable is pep centurion team
better than any club team
yeah
i
we is there like a there's probably like
a sliver between here as well because of
that's how close the two teams have been
i think the only team that's better
sorry than the century audience team and
look you're talking about the team i've
got 100 points in the league it's
ridiculous um
is
either the team that run them close the
season after
because not only did we run into the
last game of the season and you know
there's that it's so close that there's
a moment when you're down to brighton
where yeah yeah
that team also goes on and wins the
champions league that season as well i
think that's
the closest we've got maybe to being
better and oh and
the only other argument is when we got
99 points
and
we if we picked up a single point or two
points in any of those remaining games
we played about nine games behind closed
doors after restart
so there's a chance and then it'll never
be born out in the numbers because you
can't argue 100 points more points than
99 or 97
but i think
both of those teams
might have been better than that
centurion's team well i just uh
they won't better because they think
they've got their points what i'm saying
is 97s 99s 100 points that's because
them two teams were
regardless of what you say klopp will be
thinking i need to keep with pep and we
was when we had to chase you we had to
keep with club and i think they both
spurred each other on but i think the
levels that pep guardiola and klopp are
taking this premier league to now is
unbelievable these seasons we knight
your points and that but i don't think
we get enough credit when we get robbie
for example said it's a run-of-the-mill
stuff getting a hundred points never
been done in the history of football
yeah we're invincible with about 42
things that's what i'm saying so
at the end of the day manchester city to
get 100 points never be done english
football for me is a massive achievement
and one that we just take for granted
and think it is what it is but i just
think
for me it was definitely
that centurion team pips all them teams
a plot yeah no it is i i it's very
difficult to argue with that because i
say i have literally got no
factual basis to say that any of those
teams how can you say a team is better
than yourself
i think 97 points and a champions league
was better than was better than a
hundred points and no champions always
fully in the champions league
we're talking about the teams and now
he's bringing champions leagues into it
yeah the big boy big ears the biggest
trophy hardest trophy to win the one
with the most glory you know what i mean
the carabao cup's got the most glory now
there in the final you know
the last four years it was like now a
little bother without but now it's like
they're swinging off the rooftop in
liverpool yeah yeah sergio aguero's goal
versus qpr is a better moment than
istanbul 2005.
[Music]
[Laughter]
three
well for me yeah
i'm gonna go
i'm not i can't go all the way there
yeah because
i like it was a time before i really
gave any consideration to man city so it
was still like nice and novel and and
boss that they were taking the title
away from man united so i actually had
an amazing time that night i we all my
dad all in the house celebrated that
like it was a liverpool goal at that
point um
but
like
no i understand let me explain this to
you let me explain to you right imagine
growing up in in in
the 90s in manchester they're winning
european cups they're signing all the
best players in the world you're going
in school every monday just ready for it
yeah yeah i'm trying to fight cantona
off with jamie pollock
you know i mean lee bradbury they're
coming at me with andre can chelsea and
all that right it was an absolute hell
and and we tried our best you know i
mean was a merry band of brothers we
stuck together and we tried to fight it
yeah and then every time we seemed to do
something they done something we got
promoted they won the treble and this is
how it was for years and years and years
and then to finally get to the moment
where you think right we're gonna win
the league here and then we got to the
game
and i'll tell you the story about the
game i got that game and they're selling
scarce outside champions so i went up to
this guy and i went mate you better do
one with them scarce me i said you went
oh you're going to win it it's cute i
went no i said if any team can mess this
city man i went just go away with them
scarves right
and i'm sat in the stadium there were
two one down here 91 minutes and a mate
said to me i can't believe this can you
ever bought this scarf
i said to him i can't give this football
club any more than i've given it over
the years right i think you've got the
opportunity to win the league and snatch
it from the deadliest rivals so it's
like that big kid in the school yard
that's been bullying you for 20 years
you've got the chance george mcfly
you've got exactly right ivan drago
stuff like you've seen yeah
and then i'll never forget my mate text
me united fan and it come up we are the
champions
and i just sent one back saying out of
pure pride not yet you're not and as i
looked up aguero scored that goal now
the mo i've never you can't expect i've
never experienced anything like look my
ears i've been standing up on my arms
right i've never seen anything but to
snatch the title away from them like
that for a man city fan and i nearly had
heart attack i swear to god
i swear to god i was like i i i went
from being the lowest i've ever been in
my life thinking we're never going to
live this down for the rest of our lives
we're going to be the bottlers to being
champions of england but like at that
aguero moment i think is the premier
league title winning moment in history
the istanbul thing there was an
embarrassment factor there where we
didn't deserve to be in that final i've
gone back to a
that side wasn't good enough that ac
milan team like you mean the players in
in that team beyond belief how good they
are almost everyone and absolutely
world-class footballer and liverpool
just didn't have that
you go three nil down and you're like oh
my god like we're just not meant to be
here this is a joke and you think it's
just gonna be four is it gonna be five
it's an embarrassment it was one of
those just like
unreal and the fact that it it it
transcends
liverpool it transcends england it's
european i mean it's become one of those
iconic games in the history of the sport
um yeah i as i say i'd love to go if we
if we were having a if i could delete
what delete one keep one i had to then
obviously i would keep it
that's special to you that's better to
me you're never going to go against that
i don't expect you to i'm never going to
go against that but like you say both
games were just unreal yeah absolutely
one of the perfect premier league moment
manchester united's current state is
hilarious
three
two
one
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's it's glorious
absolutely glorious the best thing it's
like
oh my god it's like you've got
everything going right in your life and
then you're having a great day you've
woken up you're having a good hair day
you know everything turned out you're
having a nice breakfast you get to work
sorry and then you find and then you get
to the end of the day and you find 20
quid in your coat that man united being
crap is just like just a wonderful glory
lottery me that's what i'm thinking no
it's listen in manchester it's just it
was just painful you know what i mean
but we had to
it was always liverpool you know but
they was on us you know even when they
were winning european cups they had
banners ups mocking us in the second
division now
if if everton was in the second division
or you don't mock trammy when you was in
istanbul did you have a tram me
trammered
out like that
they was honest you know what i mean
there was on us all the time i'm like
they don't want to learn themselves
leave us alone you know what i mean this
is the best analogy you're ever going to
get on this year right this is what i
said to this united fan i said we both
lived on the same street yeah i said you
lived over the road i lived here said
you had a big massive house you had a
beautiful car a beautiful wife i said
and you had everything i wanted i said i
used to come out in the morning go
morning get in my car job drive to work
very depressed then one day i won the
lottery so i bought the house next door
here i've got a bigger swimming pool
than you i've got a bigger car than you
then i nicked your wife
i said and now you're ill with it you're
so stuck in your drive looking at me
thinking wow he's got everything i want
and that's what happened in manchester
and i just you can't have and you'll
know this better than you can't have a
conversation with my united fans about
football for the 90s
anymore they're all leaving or don't
like football anymore i mean mrs said i
can't get a season sick gotta go
shopping they've all got those harry
potter scarves on
they're all swinging in the car park
you've seen that they signed that
ronaldo and they're all swinging in the
car park it's like disneyland there now
so if you go there you have candy floss
on that and then they all sway in the
car park you set a roller coaster up in
the car park called the sweet ride yeah
and they all got on it and went sweet
and under the picture at the end that
would be their person
more overpaid players
let me show you how dedicated i am to
messi
it's great it's a nice tattoo
unfortunately
you picked the
guy wrong
unfortunately mate i didn't
oh my god